Charlie it's Oh Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool
Oh I don't know if you guys have noticed
then little YouTube secret santa thing
that's going around at the moment but um
I got my present in the post today it's
only a small thing but I don't mind I'm
sure it's going to be something really
cool inside or something I don't know
who it's prom either but I guess I'll
find out as soon as I open it up and see
what's inside
so yeah I'm gonna open it now and see
yay nice ribbon that I just destroy okay
I'm sorry inside no cool all right okay
oh my god Mario oh my god it's so cool
oh look at this look oh my god it goes
really far that's so cool right is there
a note inside as well so let's see who
sent it to me dear Charlie wishing you a
very Merry Christmas I hope you like the
Wario I know you're big Nintendo fan so
I thought I'd send you this little gift
lots of love
charlie is so cool like oh thank you
Charlie oh that's so kind of you oh
thank you so much well I guess it would
be great if I hadn't been left out with
the YouTube Secret Santa thing oh yeah
that's right
what didn't nobody want to tell Charlie
that that was going on it did look
pretty cool obviously I'm not important
enough to know these things
whatever oh and thanks to my 20000
subscribers I'll make a video for you as
soon as I come up with a good idea at
the moment I can't think of anything
other than just writing down all your
names and that might take a couple of
days so I'm gonna try and think of
something better my Christmas tree is so
much cooler than your Christmas tree
okay thanks bye